[Musique]
sa jeunesse je serai petit 4 jeux
j'écouterai une passion et je l'en
prescrire et des antilles les plus sûres
je suis le mois de janvier et c'est un
mois qui débute c'est la roma d'air
chaud un mot dans le contexte dans le
contexte de ce métier je dirais à lille
parce que dans mes doutes d'artistes
aidant mais dans mes joies d'artistes
même les gens les plus proches de toi
dans la famille dans tes amis vu qu'ils
sont pas aisées voulait pas dans le même
contexte émotionnel parce qu'on est
quand même envie quand même un truc un
peu à part et extraordinaire donc
trouver des alliés dans ce milieu dans
ce métier des gens qui te comprennent à
qui tu peux dire les choses sans avoir à
les expliquer alors et el balah
personnel du avec qui je partage tout ça
serait instagram
je me réveille je mange je dors à g
non je trouve que c'est un endroit
particulièrement créatif où on peut
s'exprimer grâce à son univers j'adore
ça
[Musique]
je parle longtemps et moins de 20 ans ne
peuvent pas connaître sa boîte ma
philosophie c'est pourtant pas ma
préférée mais je pense que c'est la
préférée des gens qui nous pour comme je
veux leur faire plaisir je tiges devant
chanté qu'une tout le temps je suis
entré seulement il faut bien choisir la
chanson parce qu'il faut pas que mes
créations je me suiciderai d'avancé sur
chicago comme un mauvais coup et je vous
dirais que c'est moi qui vais lui
proposer mien j'ai dit que je l'aimais
bien géré et non plus jusqu'à danser la
valse
c'est ce qui dans ce nom qui devrait
tourner avec louis garrel
si on peut special 6
la guerre ce serait jean michel 9 parce
que je trouve qu il se sort de toute
situation et rica qui me fait beaucoup a
[Musique]
franchi coups sûrs